dans la famille à l'idée je demande la
fille après la longue lutte de laëtitia
contre la presse et l'opinion publique
au sujet de l'héritage de johnny voilà
maintenant que c'est sa fille jade qui
crée la polémique sur les réseaux
sociaux
la raison jade qui a maintenant 15 ans a
décidé de vivre sa vie sur les réseaux
notamment sur instagram où elle poste de
nombreuses photos et ce sont justement
ces clichés qui sont en cause des photos
en maillot en jupe courte ou dans des
positions suggestives
pour de nombreux internautes ces clichés
sont inappropriées pour une jeune fille
de 15 ans alors les internautes choqués
par les postes instagram de jade à
l'idée d'accord c'est sérieux bon alors
c'est moi je vous dis moi j'ai des
filles c'est vrai que si je voyais ces
postes ma fille sur l art adam peut-être
je serai je lui dirai fait attendre non
pas que ça me choque mais évidemment ça
peut provoquer des choses et on sait à
quel point maintenant les réseaux peut
avoir des conséquences parfois
dangereuses que si l'on tombe sur un
sahara sur un cinglé ou voilà gilles
franchement moi ça me choque
ah et oui ça me choque qu'on laisse un
enfant ou une adolescente de 15 ou 16
ans 16 ans comme ça se montrer de cette
manière là enfin faire déclare que sur
des réseaux sociaux
donc c'est dangereux pour elle donc je
trouve qu'il faudrait lui expliquer
qu'il ne faut pas faire ça voilà ma part
si je vous dis moi j je pense que je
comprends ce qu'il veut dire gilles
franchement alors moi j'ai j'ai moi même
une jeune fille du même âge donc de 16
ans s'il vous plaît arrêtons un moment
l'indignation à géométrie variable ça
devient insupportable quand on ouvre moi
ma timeline d'instagram il ya des
gamines des facs ont 11 ans condé string
qui dépasse de leurs jeans sur qui fait
alors oui je suis d'accord c'est
peut-être pas mieux sauf qu'aujourd'hui
les gens les enfants vivent avec leur
temps qu'une jeune fille de 10 ans non
non non ce met at work et à faire des
chorégraphies dans avec des petites
tenues aux quêtes 10 ans et peut-être
jeune mes 16 ans elle ne fait rien de
deux suggestions
ce sont les personnes qui regardent qui
sont la plupart du temps mal
intentionnés et qui voit ce qu'est ce
qu'il faut pas voir en phase avec sa
cheminée je suis comme je suis comme
gilles ça me ça me choque moi je serais
pour les applications comme instagram
facebook etc
je ferai comme la même utilisation pour
les paris sportifs je demanderai une
poésie d'entités je ne s'agirait que des
majeurs locaux normalement en théorie
oui pas tardé honneur au mieux c'est
pour ça que ça change mais alors là je
pose une question comment com comment se
fait-il que personne ne vérifie pas
pourquoi les réseaux twitter et autres
laisse résonner pour capturer les
données les infos et puis voilà il se
sent brévine je rebondis sur ce que tu
as dit ludivine tu dis les jeunes vivent
avec leur temps
injustement c'est ça le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui le temps n'est plus entre
guillemets adapté je dis pas qu'elle
doit se soumettre à ça aujourd'hui il ya
de tels dangers par rapport au regarde
cette photo
rien que cette photo je suis désolé une
gamine de 15 ans ai je mal est au delà
de ça c'est aussi à sa mère armement
données de nos vies sous le soleil les
maka les ailes à la plage tous les jours
donc bien qu'est ce que tu as besoin
d'étaler regarde regarde le décotées
limite on voit le téton etc
je suis là aujourd'hui c'est un problème
je ne dis pas que c'est mal je dis que
cette humiliation de protection
aujourd'hui il faut protéger des jeunes
et énormément de bergers à cause d'un
coup de tous les dessins numériques sont
assez vivre comme daniel regarde moi je
veux prendre il ya très longtemps je
vais il y avait un photographe soit pas
cité absolue l'ancienne équipe qui s'est
suicidé qui des photos très positive
avec des béni les adolescents de voir
des enfants à la food & bombe à l'époque
ça jusqu'à saturer personne aimée par
ont très très peur oui moi je sais que
ma fille par exemple qui a 13 ans et ya
aussi des dizaines de milliers de
followers qui énormément suivi équipe et
déposent comme ça et moi aussi je suis
sa maman donc au début ressèment ça me
gênait etc
mais j'ai compris parce que la pauvre
elle s'en prend plein la gueule se fait
insulter de tous j'ai compris qu'en fait
à sagelat maintenant on ne peut rien
faire il faut juste les accompagner faut
pas les internautes abonnés et non
abonnés vous indiquez votre télé ou des
têtes on ne peut rien faire on bien sûr
c'est aux parents de faire moi je viens
je vais terminer si tu me laisses
terminé j'ai dit j'accompagne mon enfant
je préfère que ma fille me donne c'est
comme instagram que je vois qui elle
parle oui je surveille ce qui se passe
plutôt qu'elles le fassent dans mon bien
sûr qu'ils soient passés c'est une
réalité et c'est pas bien de se voiler
la face gynécée la fumée les gens danger
il faut pas moyen face dans l'école dans
les écoles ils sont tous sur les wii et
sur les pavés les empêche il le faut je
veux et je vais vous dire une règle
excuse-moi pas à m'en excuser moi pardon
donc ne s'est pas interdit mais en même
temps c'est pas interdit les réseaux
sociaux instagram ils ont le droit mais
je crois que c'est à partir de 13 ans où
ça doit être mis géré par un adulte et
moi et si c'est ce que je fais et
j'estime que je fêterai
mon rôle de maman gilles juste gilles
est énervé ceci dit j'ai vécu un truc à
la maison excusez moi c'est que on avait
effectivement pris les codes un stade à
la petite dernière qui a immédiatement
on recrée à notre combien cela découvert
après mois qu'elle avait un autre contre
8 hexagonales ont été des photos à celle
d'angers dialogue et l'avantagé sur
instagram c'est que c'est visible et que
justement vous pouvez le voir vous
l'avez vu qu'elle a ouvert un deuxième
il faut dialoguer avec les enfants les
frustrés il faut pas les bloquer youtube
je suis désolé je prends un exemple
concret il ya alessandra ross qui est
allée jean marc panis sur ces news tous
les matins elle qui a une trentaine
d'années qui est sur une chaîne d'info
tous les jours sur instagram un
messagerie privée elle reçoit des photos
de sexes de mecs et chacun comme ça ça
veut dire excuse ou bien est ce que je
trouve normal de 15 ans a cédé confier
des convives de ce genre de choses vous
devez entendre on le sait mais je laisse
en a parlé ensemble sur les réseaux
prennent d'été d'hérisser grand parent
bien si effectivement il faut qu'on soit
vigilant
les excuser moi les réseaux sociaux sont
responsables oui parce qu'ils doivent
contrôler les pervers et ils doivent les
musiques amplifiées mais par contre je
trouve ça une logique de punir les
enfants de vives de grandir et d'évoluer
ce n'est pas de cette manière vocale
mais non mais je suis d'accord avec
kevin les enfants n'ont pas la maturité
pour affronter ce alors que les origines
vu une fille qui va avoir 13 ans dd je
peux te dire qu'aujourd'hui et c'est
difficile et je rejoins magali
aujourd'hui de 13 ans elle est mature
mais bien sûr dire mais quand on a des
enfants tu verras ma - interdire les
enfants contre elle moi je vais dire
quelque chose
j'ai fait ce café magani cirque on a les
codes et de la femme le gère très bien
on a appris en début de semaine qu'à
paramètres ce harcelé à l'école parce
qu'on a eu les codes et qu'on a lu un
petit peu tout on a pu parler avec elle
lors de rendez vous à l'école et c'est
un match qui est je pense qu'au lieu
d'interdire les oui elle a raison il
faut accompagner les jeunes et leur
parler alors gagner dans cette manne
mois en fait pourquoi je mets non parce
que je suis d'accord avec enfin
évidemment que j'ai pas envie que les
adolescents j'ai vu votre instinct g et
bon moi j'ai l'âge même je les dépasse
et maintenant non mais la question c'est
jade à l'idée cette gamine elle a perdu
d'abord c'est que ce soit donnée à
l'idée la star ou pas elle a perdu son
père à 12 ans elle est quand même la
fille d'une femme qui est détesté mais
moi si bernard montiel disait ce qu'il
dit sur le plateau de mamers qui dit de
laetitia mejean serait traumatisé
vous vous rendez compte un petit peu ce
qu'elle se prend dans la tranche cette
gamine depuis des années et ben voilà
elle vit comme les autres adolescente je
ne suis pas d'accord avec ce genre de
photo mais la question c'est sur jade à
l'idée et je suis désolé elle n'a pas
indiqué si je m'insurge à nadine et
c'est pas un débat dans les ados les
c'est bon on peux pas m'expliquer que
c'est vrai qu'il faut être vigilant
quand même de poster des départs que des
sacs très cher et tout ça on va t'on va
continuer sa déroute on harcèle laetitia
maintenant on va resserrer les gamines
non à recife petites choses
tranquillement regarder qui a dit oui
regardez qui a du baiser que des hommes
et bien si les femmes non non non et on
l'a d'ado à la maison bercy n'avait pas
d'amis